à dijon en côte d'or le procès villepin
se poursuit dans une ambiance de plus en
plus pesant que c'est le cas de le dire
la déposition des experts en graphologie
jette le trouble à l'audience beaucoup
affirment que l'écriture du corbeau
ressemble beaucoup plus à celle de
christine villemin qu'à celle du défunt
bernard laroche à dijon on retrouve tout
de suite dominique verdeilhan gibrat
gries dans les serviettes de l'expert
jean glénisson les tests de comparaison
en écriture et pour lui aussi il y a des
similitudes extraordinaire entre les
écrits du corbeau et ceux de christine
villemin
des ressemblances qui porte sur des
repères caractéristiques en graphologie
nous n'avions aucune idée préconçue nous
étions très mal à l'aise car nous
savions que nous désignons la mère de
l'enfant christine villemin présente
dans la salle a les traits tendus le
visage fermé
la partie civile invite à se rapprocher
du grand écran où sont projetées des
tests je peux carrément allé m'asseoir
dans le box lance-t-elle au président
ruyssen quelque peu déboussolés jean
marie villemin à son tour s'adresse à la
cour si m prompt considère que la reine
non lieu n'a aucune valeur qu'il dépose
des conclusions et que christine
viennent s'asseoir à côté de moi une
deuxième expertise qui sera remise au
juge lambert le 4 juillet 1985
le lendemain ce dernier inculpé et
incarcéré
christine villemin la première expertise
celle qui a été évoquée hier et qui
aboutissent et aux mêmes conclusions
avaient été signifiée aux parties le 25
mars 85
quatre jours plus tard jean-marie
villemin assassiné bernard laroche